when i was speaking with carla rivelli
he said there are two interpretations of
quantum mechanics that he feels like are
consistent relational quantum mechanics
and then the many worlds
right of course but he doesn't like the
many worlds interpretation so he chooses
the relational one now from my
understanding of your views there can't
be a wave function of the universe
because this can't just simply evolve in
time determinately is that an incorrect
reading
correct correct
okay now does that mean that you don't
believe in the many worlds
interpretation
no not not at all i think that's quite a
an empty concept and i think the
explanatory power of many worlds is
essentially
zero uh again it's it's again one of
these things which is super
deterministic you know that is the
initial uh wave function of the universe
and then everything evolves according to
that and
there is never any event that happens
nothing really happens it just is this
unitary evolution which is an enormous
uh
rotation in this gigantic hilbert space
that's something that there's nothing
happening there you cannot tell a story
here
um no no so my view and much closer i'm
not claiming that i have the solution to
all these problems but my
my feeling is much closer my heart is
much closer to a
spontaneous localization
theory so stochastic evolution of the
the schrodinger equation
and so in this way also the you know as
time passes this uh
schrodinger equation of this wave
function sorry gets added
additional uh information a bit like my
my numbers for classical mechanics
and as time passes this additional
information that gets added to the to
the wave function may localize it here
or there
with appropriate probabilities and we
are stochastic equations doing that
perfectly